so maybe i might have this wrong let me
see if I have it right I'm getting the
sense that you're more comfortable and
sort of like pursuing feature films and
like this is the path you want to be on
and yet you do have chutes and ladders
the initial web series so it's like how
did that come about like if you if you
you know like if it did it take you
doing this series to realize that I
probably I think I mean well the way
that happened um is that I was tired of
waiting for him you know something to
get produced in order to do something I
just wanted to go out and shoot
something um and so that's why we
decided a let's make a web series um
because we can do that on our own um you
know it's not it's not going to look
fantastic but it will be a great
learning experience and so that's how he
I treated the first season of shoots it
was it was a learning experience and it
was awesome and it was awesome because
we got to work with some other new
people some very experienced people it
was a good balance and um it was great
to kind of grow together and she still
be able to to put out uh you know put up
a season that the that we're proud of
but I think the reason that we did a web
series to start with was because it was
a chance to grow and to learn and so
that the next time we wanted to dive
into a project you know we'd have that
experience under our belt yeah and I
think yeah i mean that's that's what I
ultimately came down to its like you you
can spend forever waiting but the web
format is in a sense kind of more
forgiving because it's so new so I mean
there's everything from like vlogs to to
host it shows to you know like there's
so there's such a variety of things that
you can kind of fit your way into that
and I mean with this kind of thing I
mean you can only learn by doing you can
you can read as much as you want you can
talk to other people but until you
actually do it you don't you don't
really know and you know we wanted to do
it cheaply and you know for the
experience to learn and and if it was a
complete failure or we could
get through that okay like that's what
you learn but I think that's sort of
where that came from where where you
know we can make this we can do it on
our own we can put it up we can see what
happens and then grow from there
you